[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you're about to see a motion picture
which is going to help you to understand
more clearly some of the physical and
emotional symptoms that have been
bothering you and which are responsible
for you being here as patients in this
hospital to explain the causes of your
symptoms to you we're going to show you
among other things some combat scenes
scenes just like those some of you have
been in now they may upset you but just
remember that no one ever had an
operation or an illness or at a broken
leg fixed without experiencing a little
pain and it's the same way with feelings
when we dislodge sore feelings we have
to pry them loose like a bad tooth and
that hurts expect it to hurt a little
and strangely enough you'll find it
doesn't hurt half as much as you
anticipate so now let's get started
the natural place to start is with fear
everybody is afraid some of the time and
everybody going into battle
is always afraid at least if they're
normal like us and that's a good thing
for fear has its uses it makes us alert
sends the blood through our veins gives
us strength than the sharpness let's
take a simple example here's a cat
behaving in a perfectly normal manner
eating its supper but what happens when
our natural enemy the dog walks by she
immediately gets into condition red and
condition red means that an attack is
imminent so she's on her guard yet being
on guard
looks like fear and that's the clue
being on guard is fear fear is the
body's way of getting into condition red
she is as you were at your battle
stations and in your foxholes all set to
go that's nature's logical answer to
danger fear fear keys you up set your
heart pounding gives you that tingling
feeling in your legs and up and down
your spine
it makes your mouth dry and causes the
all-gone feeling in the pit of your
stomach you get restless you're on your
mark set to go
come on get the letter
but you know all about this let's go
back to our ket he can teach us a lot
when the dog her enemy goes fear goes
with him and everything comes back to
normal once again
she's a peaceful tabby enjoying her
supper white as if nothing had happened
once our danger has passed you and I
react in the same way go back to our
normal occupations with one difference
we remember and sometimes this
remembering business is so real it won't
let us relax and keeps us on our guard
even though there's nothing happening to
make us afraid for instance here's a
hospital ward probably pretty much like
the one you're in and you know how the
men next to you how you yourself act
when you're asleep
these fellows like you are behaving as
if the enemy were right down the
corridor or outside the window there
remembering always remembering this is
patient corporal Ben Edwards
United States Marine Corps if we find
out Edwards trouble it will help us to
understand what's happening to these
other men and what's more to the point
it will help us find out what the
trouble is
with you as you can see Ed bridges
having a rough time of it and you don't
have a rough time like this without
there being a cause for it to discover
that cause we'll have to see what he's
dreaming about
well that's why Edwards is tired each
morning possibly it's the same sort of
thing that makes you feel all wrung out
these mornings too you can see that he's
remembering some battle he was in or at
least parts of it and that his
remembering has no relationship to where
he is in the safe hospital far away from
the enemy so now let's go back to the
beginning and see how this came about
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so I said to her for Christ's sake
you've had everything I got and now you
want a cup of coffee
gee what a lousy page wonder how much
long before we get this for seven days
out seven days without a long time No
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
you have to go out I like there's some
law about wetting a uniform government
property and something wouldn't be the
war with it nothing like that oh nothing
like that
won't be long anyway maybe tomorrow and
you can apply whenever you want to you
know what a battle is all about I think
it'll be tomorrow hope so probably kind
of heat up being a sailor sure does
we must be a thousand miles north of
Tulagi
yeah West jeez for a butter you sure can
contradict again well that's what a
buddy's for oh is that what you're gonna
do with the Japs yeah this kids that's
all
wait'll they get there yeah seven days
to be soon now well that's where it
began you can see that corporal Edwards
is excited maybe the chap with the dry
pipe is right maybe he is behaving like
a kid but that's because he and his
buddy Hal are tense and all the other
men with him each in his own way they're
beginning to be afraid dreading what
will happen in battle wondering whether
they will master their fear or whether
it will defeat them and the answer to
that they don't find out until the seven
days have become eight or nine or two
weeks and they are wherever it is the
enemy is
therefore those GI pants it's like get a
get got alright that's it
they're like the cat they're seeing
their enemy and they're scared but
they're not yellow all those symptoms he
had were to get him ready for this to
make him a good fighting man
he's using his fear just as you did at
first to make him team aware of every
danger about him so that he can meet it
sure is afraid and so is every other man
but see how his fear helps him see it
snap that rifle in the firing position
see it carry him forward pursuing the
enemy see it give him almost second
sight edward is a good corporal he's
really fighting because his fear has
been useful to him
take it easy Murali
knock it off they're on the run dig in
here make this your position and hold it
I asked oh I meant how is it out there
it's pretty quiet we'll keep her on you
and stone going ahead for security
alright fellas shovel it deep chubby
over then that scrub for you that's a
good spot Lorenson hold it over that
tree how you and I'll dig here
[Music]
still and like apple pie better I don't
know my money I'll take that Swan
I mean the one with hair on our legs
yeah blonde hair
said I liked apple pie better the
bastards don't know where we are
come on let's get going
you see the immediate danger has been
removed at least it's not so bad as it
was
and so they joke and are again not
afraid their fear was useful to them in
the battle now they don't need it and so
it disappears if it weren't to disappear
now then the men would not be well but
like the cat they have lost their
symptoms their dog is off in the jungle
and their fear has gone with him their
fear has served its purpose making them
angry putting them in condition red it's
been a beneficial tool in the time of
crisis it appeared when it was needed
but don't forget however corporal
Edwards remembers everything that has
happened now he knows what fear is like
from this time on his knowledge is
always with him let's see where it leads
they'd only be sure that sons of [ __ ]
weren't out there my old mother told me
there'd be days like this yeah why
didn't you shoot it Carlos knock it out
thank you much noise sure make things a
hell of a lot easier if you could sing
[Music]
well you got to teach that marksmanship
yeah their chest must look mighty
there's one what they're doing with all
that tin they got in Singapore
[Applause]
I don't know why you guys bought a
scrubbing clothes with all those shots
riffle makes a hell of a good washing
machine
Christ I think go to sleep like this
where are they
I don't think that it's a week since we
heard
eight days and five hours
okay Jesus who'd have thought it'd have
been like this for weeks in this
goddamned hole for weeks of lying on
your belly and feeding her mosquitoes
yeah it's getting so I'm forgetting
everything else including what a man
lives for
even Sarah and clueless era and and
that's simcha truck
there isn't a goddamn chapter so why in
hell don't we do something about it why
don't we get a move on
why don't we take over
come on let's let's get him out of here
now to cook food all you have to do is
put this up yeah son don't get it the
maggots world neither case brother
you'll lean it handle like K rations
x-ray
[Applause]
every day every damn day what are they
gonna let us see
[Music]
we've only shown you part of all that
happened just little incidents through
the weeks but I guess you can see where
Edwards is going and why he's been kept
always on the alert those fear responses
haven't had much chance to relax because
the enemy the danger is always present
it's just as if the dog never went away
from the cat left the cat always like
this naturally you can't freeze forever
in a position like this something's
bound to give but usually such events as
you have seen are not enough to cause
combat fatigue some climax has to happen
and with Edwards this is what it was
where and by the way this is the last of
our really noisy scenes so please bear
with us you already know what we're
going to do anybody have any questions
before we go all right when we leave
here you'll medal the machine-gun go
back join your outfit we're going to
clean up the Japs between here and the
river office will be the right assault
Batum and we'll move out of here a
collar towards the assembly area we move
out keep at least five cases there might
be some snipers do all of your rations
and ammunition
all right sergeant you move altimeter
lids down this trail
I'll meet you at the fog all right let's
go
five please
right out
it could have been me
well that's it
now we know what corporal Edwards dreams
about every night in the hospital but
why because he'd had as much as he could
take he'd been too full of fear too long
not that he's a coward you've seen that
he isn't but there's a point in every
man in every man beyond which he cannot
go that point with Edwards was reached
when his buddy was killed it could have
been something else
it just happened it with Edwards that's
what it was from now on you will see
that Edwards no longer behaves like
himself everything he does or says is a
symptom of illness as his friends put it
it's got him
but if we interpret these symptoms will
see that what looks like mysterious or
strange behavior isn't so illogical
after all but has meaning and purpose
it's just that Edwards won't accept fear
won't admit that he's reached his
breaking point
a me that is mother
goddamn thing will work never did work
and never will work don't try to rush it
sure it'll work I said it wouldn't deny
any good anyway I think they sent us the
best what's in your pants red ants did
you get hit but we're the ones who are
fighting us war if they give us
something to fight it with they sent for
the army to come to Tulagi but General
MacArthur said no and this is the reason
it isn't
[Music]
[Music]
there behind that tree there was a [ __ ]
sir
Assam so I shot him fact remains AdWords
that you fired
you knew the orders he knew it meant the
Brig if you shot at random yes why did
you do it what was a chapter sir
twig snapped and I saw something move I
saw him very clearly was a jack did you
kill him behind the tree something moved
I saw him and I shot him
did anybody find the body I shot him I
see
not feeling very well are you corporal
no sir
how's your appetite it's lousy what I do
eat won't stick it to slum we get here
are you sure of that
well I vomit don't I yes I guess you do
well there's the story perhaps you
recognize the symptoms nerves and
jumpiness hostility insomnia vomiting
probably he tell you he had headaches if
you ask him for diarrhea
he's lost his sense of proportion - he
knows deep inside himself that there was
no [ __ ] behind those leaves but he won't
admit it
not even to himself now how does all
this come about well you remember our
cat and that the cat had all these
physical symptoms of fear and you
remember that Edwards had those same
symptoms the blood rushed from his
stomach his heart pounded his hands were
sweaty and that didn't happen once but
many times over and over again and the
load kept getting bigger and bigger
always increasing until it was just too
big a load to carry and since he
remembered all the times he got so he
had the symptoms even when there was no
cause that's why he couldn't hold his
food any longer his stomach was
physically constricted with his fear and
so he vomited you know that men going
into battle often vomit or soiler pants
will men who carry their fear with him
after the battle go on doing the same
things because their bodies are always
in condition red and that's why Edwards
is here in the hospital because he can't
forget he always acts as if there were
an enemy president on a peaceful street
he behaves as if there were a [ __ ] ready
to jump from behind any parked car if
somebody dropped something near him he
thinks a mortars got his number or that
he's being dive-bomb maybe instead of
getting it out you've got it inside and
it hangs in your chest like a lump of
lead or maybe you've thought about it so
much that it makes your head swim and
you're dizzy or maybe you're like the
patient I saw the other day who took it
out on his pals and his wife acted as if
they were the Japs and the jerries and
was
it's an irritable that's fear if you'd
call it by its right name and don't
blame your stomach for your eyes or your
bowels or acting the way nature intended
them to act when you're scared yes it
sounds simple but the cure is far from
easy
that's why your doctor sees you so often
that's why you have to do physical work
go to discussion groups play games learn
about the happenings of the world you're
getting well because you're learning
what fear is and how to handle it and
when you get your problem worked out
you'll find you don't fight against fear
you just get it lined up so that it
works to your best interests when you're
face to face with the enemy as soon as
you've learned that the bullet shot at
you yesterday or last month or last year
and hurt you today you've learned the
first big lesson then and only then you
get into condition red at the right time
and in the right place you accept fear
as part of living something to be taken
as a help not as a handicap you and
Edwards and the other boys one fine day
will be as fit as a new Silver Dollar
and you'll be shoving off well not only
better
but better than ever because you've
learned something that can only be
learned the hard way that fear is a
fighting man's friend if he learns how
to run it and not be run by
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]